>> Tucker: THERE WAS A
DEVELOPMENT IN BRITNEY SPEARS
CONSERVATORSHIP WHICH WE ARE
COVERING AS A STORY.
TRACE GALLAGHER WITH US.
>> UNCLEAR EXACTLY HOW THAT ROAD
IS, COURT DOCUMENTS SHOW HER
FATHER JAMIE SPEARS IS WILLING
TO STEP DOWN AS HER CONSERVATOR
WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT FOR THE
COURT PAPERS SHOW THAT JAMIE
SPEARS STILL BELIEVES HE IS THE
BEST PERSON TO HANDLE HIS
DAUGHTER'S FINANCIAL AFFAIRS AND
ALSO BELIEVES THAT THERE ARE NO
LEGAL GROUNDS FOR REMOVING HIM,
BUT JAMIE SPEARS OF BOWSER'S
ATTORNEY WRITES IN PART QUOTING
HERE THAT EVEN AS MR. SPEARS IS
THE UNREMITTING TARGET OF
UNJUSTIFIED ATTACKS, HE DOES NOT
BELIEVE THAT A PUBLIC BATTLE
WITH HIS DAUGHTER OVER HIS
CONTINUING SERVICE AS HER
CONSERVATOR WOULD BE IN HER BEST
INTEREST.
SO IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHEN.
BRITNEY SPEARS ATTORNEY CALLS IT
VINDICATION AND IS PLEASED THAT
JAMIE SPEARS HAS AGREED TO BE
REPLACED PER JAMIE SPEARS OF
COURSE HAS BEEN HIS DAUGHTER'S
CONSERVATOR SINCE SHE SUFFERED A
VERY PUBLIC BREAKDOWN 13 YEARS
AGO.
BUT DURING THOSE 13 YEARS,
BRITNEY HAS REPEATEDLY TOURED
THE WORLD AND RELEASED MULTIPLE
ALBUMS.
HER FANS SAY THAT SHE CAN TAKE
CARE OF HERSELF.